[Music]
today's question comes from lucas in
maryland i am currently on in baby step
two working on paying off the remainder
of our student loan debt we have paid at
69 000 but have a balance of 38 000 we
paid off our home we make a hundred
thousand a year i have an extensive
firearm collection
that i could sell off a portion of and
pay it off tomorrow but i'm hesitant to
do that
as i am afraid i wouldn't be able to
replace many of them
should i sell them to pay off the debt
tomorrow or keep moving the way i am and
pay it off by
december i don't know firearms are kind
of in your uh in your bucket of life i'm
not sure how much i could speak into
that
uh
i'm an extension of having extensive
purse collection
there we go now we'll make it make it
real all right all right you're working
with me okay uh
i mean i don't know i would be i would
be interested in your take on this
because for me i'm like okay you make
100 grand a year you have 38 000
and you have a plan paid off by december
you could just keep trucking along easy
enough yeah easy enough and pay it off
without having the thing i would do is
this in any collection i have and i'm a
collector of things oh we know i have an
ocd
side to me i collect used water skis i
collect firearms i've got
i'm just like i get i get off on
something i go down the whole rabbit
hole and don't get out so collector
hoarder
fine of that yeah so anyway the um
this is not about me
uh so what i would tell you though as
one firearm guy to another guy that has
an extensive collection
i don't know what you mean by extensive
collection okay if you have an extensive
collection that is worth
uh
three hundred thousand dollars
okay
and you can sell off ten percent of it
and pay this off today
you probably have ten percent of stuff
around the edges of that collection that
you don't care that much about
that's not in the sweet spot
those are not your babies you know
they're not safe queens as we call them
and so um the uh
you know you but but you know if your
entire collection is
80 000 and you'll be selling half of it
then you're probably cutting out a
little bit of your heart
when you do that so i think that's what
you got to ask yourself and just say
okay is it worth it
is there some of these items that i care
more about being dead on being out of
debt on than i do the other way i will
tell you this
if if the numbers were different if it
was going to be an extended period of
time yes i don't care three years yeah i
just i'd be selling your stuff man yeah
yep and uh i will never forget in
financial peace university years ago
when i was teaching it live with an
overhead projector this big old guy is a
linebacker looking guy completely ripped
probably you know 260 pounds muscles
everywhere
blonde headed guy
uh country boy
uh he and his little bitty nurse wife
were sitting there and she starts
telling the group
what her husband had done to get out of
debt and she's just
crying
and i'm like what in the world
and she said he has had this knife
collection
that was his prize most prized
possession
and um he sold it for twelve thousand
dollars and we paid off all of our debt
last week because he loves he he said i
love you and my kids more than i love my
knife wow
and what that spoke to her that it just
screamed at her i love you
and and the whole place is just like
giving him a standing ovation because
that's a man yeah that's a that's a
grown-up who will sacrifice for the good
of this stuff for their future and it's
just stuff so in that sense if these
numbers were different lucas i would be
putting you in that category and saying
dude sell your guns yeah yeah
sell your guns they're just guns i mean
it's just fun but you you've got the
income your debt-free house and
everything you're down to the last 38
000. you're going to get there pretty
quick anyway
so i'm not it's a different discussion
with the same thing be for like a like i
remember being on the show i think i was
with ken maybe when we were hosting and
a guy had a collector car
that he just loved love love loved and
he's like i could sell and be out of
debt today or i could be out of debt
again there's some situations like that
some collector cars okay my dad and i
rebuilt this mustang 500 hours when i
was 14 through 17 years old i'm 42.
you don't sell that car that's like
selling your wedding ring
yeah okay i wouldn't ask you to sell
your wedding ring either to get out of
debt
but uh i bought this car a few years ago
and it's kind of fun
you sell that car yeah yeah
you know if you're in if you're in if
you've got yourself into a mess because
you've you know you gave up the right to
own something like that because you'd
already spent the money yes and so yeah
so but there's some things that have
some nostalgic value or if in this
firearms collection was a musket from
his great grandfather that he used you
know to protect the fort or what i don't
know you know whatever you whatever you
come you don't sell that gun okay that's
a family heirloom that's not a it's not
a collection item unless it doesn't mean
much to you and it's a family heirloom
that's just sitting there and you're
like i don't really don't sell that gun
because you'll wake up later and it'll
mean something to you if it was
that that
you know like well my wedding ring
doesn't mean that much to me yeah you're
gonna regret that don't do that that's
just that that's gonna come you're
you're a little bit too enthused about
getting out of debt right now you need
to calm down about one notch you know
no i mean really you don't sell wedding
has slowed down well you don't the
gazelle doesn't sell its wedding ring it
just runs okay
don't stop and sell your wedding ring
keep running but yeah
no it's good it's a good that's good
somebody's gonna send me little cartoons
of gazelles with whatever they're so mad
at you they're people
no but it's a good
it's a good um
because i feel like getting out of debt
it's not a balanced thing you're not
balanced when you're gonna have that you
are doing everything humanly possible to
get out of debt it's that intensity and
the more you sacrifice the faster you're
going to do it and there's that final
one that's correct
yes you plug in that small human element
and say okay
what's worth it okay there used to be a
lady there used to be a lady that had a
newsletter back when there were paper
newsletters
that uh her way of getting money was she
she didn't ever buy anything she went
and got in dumpsters and got stuff out
of dumpsters dumpster diving
okay
i'm not doing that
and i'm not recommending people do that
okay if you want to do it i'm not mad at
you but that's like homeless people
stuff okay i'm not dumpster diving
because to get out of debt that's that
last one percent of crazy yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i'm not going in the lab like
we're gonna sell our house
i'm gonna put you up on 99 crazy but i'm
not going into the last one
and that's selling the wedding ring
selling the car that your dad and you
rebuilt for 500 hours when you were 14
that's uh
selling a family heirloom or a special
place or in this case it's a short
period of time that you're gaining yeah
an uber short period of time and so it's
it you know i'm not going to sell
something that's hard to replace a lot
of guns you can get another one
depending on what it is but if you've
got a unique piece that's probably one
or you know one of 50 or something
you're probably not going to find that
one again
these aren't guns you shoot people these
are collectibles
and so um
but that's you know
that that's good
yep i think it's great it's a balanced
approach and it's good hearing that
perspective because
it gives a lot because we all have
something like that right it's like that
human element so it's good great
question lucas appreciate you writing
into us brother this is the ramsey show